I was excited to be a part of the dream
theme and then I found out I'm leading
off the nightmare a section of it and
and certainly there are things about the
climate crisis that qualify and I have
some bad news but I have a lot more good
news I'm going to propose three
questions and the answer to the first
one necessarily involves little bad news
but hang on because the answers to the
second and third questions really are
very positive so the first question is
do we really have to change and of
course the Apollo mission among other
things changed the environmental
movement really launched the modern
environmental movement eighteen months
after this earth rised picture was first
seen on earth the first Earth Day was
organized and we learned a lot about
ourselves looking back at our planet
from space and one of the things that we
learned confirmed what the scientists
have long told us one of the most
essential facts about the climate crisis
has to do with the sky as this picture
illustrates the sky is not the vast and
limitless expanse it appears when we
look up from the ground it is a very
thin shell of atmosphere surrounding the
planet that right now is the open sewer
for our industrial civilization as it's
currently organized we are spewing 110
million tons of heat trapping global
warming pollution into it every 24 hours
free of charge go ahead and there are
many sources of the greenhouse gases I'm
certainly not going to go through them
all I'm going to focus on the main one
but agriculture is involved diet is
involved population is involved
management of forests transportation the
oceans the melting of the
permafrost but I'm going to focus on the
heart of the problem which is the fact
that we still rely on dirty carbon-based
fuels for 85% of all the energy that our
world burns every year and you can see
from this image that after World War two
the emission rates started really
accelerating and the accumulated amount
of manmade global warming pollution that
is up in the atmosphere now traps as
much extra heat energy as would be
released by four hundred thousand
Hiroshima class atomic bombs exploding
every 24 hours 365 days a year
fact-checked over and over again
conservative it's the truth now it's a
big planet but that is a lot of energy
particularly when you multiply it
400,000 times per day and all that extra
heat energy is heating up the atmosphere
the whole earth system let's look at the
atmosphere this is a depiction of what
we used to think of as the normal
distribution of temperatures the white
represent normal temperature days 1951
to 1980 arbitrarily chosen the blue are
cooler than average days the red are
warmer than average days but the entire
curve has moved to the right in the
1980s and you'll see in the lower right
hand corner the appearance of
statistically significant numbers of
extremely hot days in the 90s the curve
shifted further and in the last ten
years you see the extremely hot days are
now more numerous than the cooler than
average days in fact they are 150 times
more common on the surface of the earth
them they were just thirty years ago so
we're having record-breaking
temperatures 14 of the 15 hottest years
ever measured with instruments have been
in this young century and the hottest of
all was
last month was the 370 first month in a
row warmer than the 20th century average
and the for the first time not only the
warmest January but for the first time
it was more than two degrees Fahrenheit
warmer
then the average these higher
temperatures are having an effect on
animals plants people ecosystems but on
a global basis ninety-three percent of
all the extra heat energy is trapped in
the oceans and the scientists can
measure the heat buildup much more
precisely now at all depths deep
mid-ocean the first few hundred meters
and this too is accelerating it goes
back more than a century and more than
half of the increase has been in the
last 19 years this has consequences
first-order consequence the ocean based
storms gets stronger super typhoon
Haiyan went over areas of the Pacific
five-and-a-half degrees Fahrenheit
warmer than normal before it slammed
into Tacloban as the most destructive
storm ever to make landfall Pope Francis
who has made such a difference to this
whole issue visited Tacloban right after
that superstorm sandy went over areas of
the Atlantic nine degrees warmer than
normal before slamming into New York and
New Jersey the second-order consequences
are affecting all of us right now the
warmer oceans are evaporating much more
water vapor into the skies average
humidity Worldwide's gone up more than
four percent and it creates these
atmospheric rivers the Brazilian
scientists call them flying rivers and
they funnel all of that extra water
vapor over the land where storm
conditions trigger these massive
record-breaking downpours this is from
Montana take a look at this storm last
August as it moves over Tucson Arizona
it literally splashes off the city these
downpours are really unusual last of
July in Houston Texas it rained for two
days 162 billion gallons that represents
more than two days of the full flow of
Niagara Falls in the middle of the city
which was of course paralyzed these
record downpours are creating historic
floods and mudslides this one is from
Chile last year and you'll see that
warehouse go
going by their oil tanker cars going by
this is from Spain last September you
could call this the running of the cars
and trucks I guess every night on the TV
news now is like a nature hike through
the book of Revelation I mean really the
insurance industry has certainly noticed
the losses have been mounting up they're
not under any illusions about what's
happening and the causality requires a
moment of discussion we're used to
thinking of linear cause and linear
effect one cause one effect this is
systemic causation as the great Kevin
Trenberth says all storms are different
now there's so much extra energy in the
atmosphere there's so much extra water
vapor every storm is different now so
the same extra heat pulls the soil
moisture out of the ground and causes
these deeper longer more pervasive
droughts and many of them are underway
right now it dries out the vegetation
and causes more fires in the western
part of North America there's certainly
been evidence of that a lot of them more
lightning as the heat energy builds up
there's a considerable amount of
additional lightning
also these climate-related disasters
also have geopolitical consequences and
create instability the climate related
historic drought that started in syria
in 2006 destroyed 60% of the farms in
syria killed 80% of the livestock and
drove one and a half million climate
refugees into the cities of Syria where
they collided with another one and a
half million refugees from the Iraq war
and along with other factors that opened
the gates of hell that people are trying
to close now the US Defense Department
has long warned of consequences from the
climate crisis including refugees
including food and water shortages and
pandemic disease right now we're seeing
microbial diseases from the tropics
spread to the higher latitudes the
transportation
evolution has had a lot to do with this
but the changing conditions change the
latitudes in the areas where these
microbial diseases can can become
endemic and change the range of the the
vectors like mosquitoes and ticks that
carry them the Zika epidemic now we're
better positioned in North America
because it's still a little too cool and
we have a better public health system
but when women in some regions of South
and Central America are advised not to
get pregnant for two years that's
something new that ought to get our
attention The Lancet one of the two
greatest medical journals in the world
last summer labeled this a medical
emergency now and there are many factors
because of it this is also connected to
the extinction crisis were in danger of
losing 50% of all the living species on
earth by the end of this century and
already land-based plants and animals
are now moving toward the poles at an
average rate of 15 feet per day speaking
of the North Pole last December 29th the
same storm that caused his stark
flooding in the American Midwest raised
temperatures at the North Pole 50
degrees Fahrenheit warmer than normal
causing the thawing of the North Pole in
the middle of the long dark winter polar
night and when the land-based ice of the
Arctic melts it raises sea level Paul
nickens beautiful photograph from
Svalbard
illustrates this it's more dangerous
coming off Greenland and particularly
Antarctica the 10 largest risk cities
for sea-level rise by population are
mostly in South and Southeast Asia when
you measure it by assets at risk
number one is Miami three and a half
trillion dollars at risk number three
New York and Newark I was in Miami last
fall during the super moon one of the
highest high tide days and there were
fish from the ocean swimming in some of
the streets of Miami Beach and Fort
Lauderdale and Delray and this happens
regularly during the highest high tides
now not with rain they call it sunny day
flooding it comes up through the
storm sewers and the mayor of Miami
speaks for many when he says it is long
past time this can be viewed through a
partisan lens this is a crisis that's
getting worse day by day we have to move
beyond partisanship and I want to take a
moment to honor these House Republicans
who had the courage last fall to step
out and take a political risk by by
telling the truth about the climate
crisis so the cost of the climate crisis
is mounting up there are many of these
aspects I haven't even mentioned it's an
enormous burden I'll mention just one
more because the World Economic Forum
last month in Davos after their annual
survey of 750 economists said the
climate crisis is now the number one
risk to the global economy so you get
central bankers like Mark Carney the
head of the UK central bank saying the
vast majority of the carbon reserves are
unburnable subprime carbon i'm not going
to remind you of what happened with
subprime mortgages but it's the same
thing if you look at all of the carbon
fuels that were burned since the
beginning of the industrial revolution
this is the quantity burned in the last
16 years here are all the ones that are
proven and left on the books twenty
eight trillion dollars the International
Energy Agency says only this amount can
be burned so the rest 22 trillion
dollars unburnable risk to the global
economy that's why the divestment
movement makes practical sense and not
just is a moral imperative now so the
answer to the first question must we
change is yes we have to change second
question can we change this is the
exciting news the best projections in
the world sixteen years ago were that by
2010 the world would be able to install
30 gigawatts of wind capacity we beat
that mark by 14 and a half times over we
see an exponential curve for wind
installations now we see the cost coming
down dramatically some countries
Germany an industrial powerhouse with a
climate not that different from
Vancouver's by the way one day last
December got 81 percent of all of its
energy from renewable sources mainly
solar and when a lot of countries are
getting more than half on an average
basis more good news energy storage from
batteries particularly is now beginning
to take off because the cost has been
coming down very dramatically to solve
the intermittency problem with solar the
news is even more exciting the best
projections 14 years ago were that we
would install one gigawatt per year by
2010 when 2010 came around we beat that
mark by 17 times over last year we beat
it by 58 times over this year we're on
track to beat at 68 times over we're
going to win this we are going to
prevail the exponential curve on solar
is even steeper and more dramatic when I
came to this stage 10 years ago this is
where it was we have seen a
revolutionary breakthrough in the
emergence of these exponential curves
and the cost has come down 10% per year
for 30 years and it's continuing to come
down now the business community has
certainly noticed this because it's
crossing the grid parity point cheaper
solar penetration rates are beginning to
rise grid parity is understood as that
line that threshold below which
renewable electricity is cheaper than
electricity from burning fossil fuels
that threshold is a little bit like the
difference between 32 degrees Fahrenheit
and 33 degrees Fahrenheit or 0 and1
celsius it's a difference of more than
one degree it's the difference between
ice and water and in markets it's the
difference between markets that are
frozen up and liquid flows of capital
into new opportunities for investment
this is the biggest new business
opportunity in the history of the world
and 2/3 of it is in the private sector
we are seeing an explosion of new
investment starting in 2010 investments
globally in renewable electricity
generation surpass
the gap has been growing ever since are
the projections for the future are even
more dramatic
even though fossil energy is now still
subsidized at a rate 40 times larger
than renewables and by the way if you
add the projections for nuclear on here
and particularly if you assume that the
work many are doing to try to break
through to safer and more acceptable
more affordable forms of nuclear this
could change even more dramatically so
is there any precedent for such a rapid
adoption of a new technology well there
are many but let's look at cell phones
in 1988 t-then Ma Bell commissioned
McKenzie to do a global market survey of
those clunky new mobile phones that
appeared then how many can we sell by
the year 2000 they asked McKenzie came
back and said 900,000 and sure enough
when the year 2000 arrived they did sell
900,000 in the first three days and for
the balance of the year they sold a
hundred and twenty times more and now
there are more cell connections than
there are people in the world so why
were they not only wrong but way wrong
I've asked that question myself why and
I think the answer is in three parts
first the cost came down much faster
than anybody expected even as the
quality went up and low-income countries
places that did not have a landline grid
they leapfrog to the new technology the
big expansion has been in the developing
countries so what about the electricity
grids in the developing world well not
so hot and in many areas they don't
exist there are more people without any
electricity at all in India than the
entire population of the United States
of America so now we're getting this
solar panels on grass huts and new
business models that make it affordable
Muhammad Yunus financed this one in
Bangladesh with a microcredit this is a
village market Bangladesh is now the
fastest deploying country in the world
two systems per minute on average night
and day and we have all we need enough
energy from the Sun comes to the earth
every hour to supply the full world's
energy needs for an entire year it's
actually a little bit less than an hour
so the answer to the second
question can we change is clearly yes
and it's an ever firmer yes now so last
question will we change Paris really was
a breakthrough some of the provisions
are binding and the regular reviews will
matter a lot but nations aren't waiting
they're going ahead China has already
announced that starting next year
they're adopting a nationwide
cap-and-trade system they will likely
link up with the European Union the
United States has already been changing
all of these coal plants were proposed
in the last 10 years and canceled all of
these existing coal plants were retired
all of these coal plants have had their
retirement announced all of them
canceled we are moving forward last year
if you look at all of the investment in
new electricity generation in the United
States almost three-quarters was from
renewable energy mostly wind and solar
we are solving this crisis the only
question is how long will it take to get
there
so it matters that a lot of people are
organizing to insist on this change now
almost 400,000 people marched in New
York City before the UN special session
on this many thousands tens of thousands
marched in cities around the world and
so I am extremely optimistic as I said
before we are going to win this I'll
finish with this story when I was 13
years old I heard that proposal by
President Kennedy to land a person on
the moon and bring him back safely in 10
years and I heard adults of that day and
time say that's reckless expensive may
well fail but eight years and two months
later in the moment that Neil Armstrong
set foot on the moon
there was a great cheer that went up in
NASA's Mission Control in Houston here
is a little-known fact about that the
average age of the systems engineers the
controllers in the room that day was 26
which means among other things their age
when they heard that challenge was 18 we
now have a moral challenge that is in
the tradition
others that we have faced one of the
greatest poets of the last century in
the u.s. Wallace Stevens wrote a line
that has stayed with me after the final
note there comes a yes and on that yes
the future world depends when the
abolitionists started their movement
they met with no after no after no and
then came a yes the women's suffrage and
women's rights movement met endless nose
until finally there was a yes the civil
rights movement the movement against
apartheid and more recently the movement
for gay and lesbian rights here in the
United States and elsewhere after the
final no comes a yes when any great
moral challenge is ultimately resolved
into a binary choice between what is
right and what is wrong the outcome is
for ordained because of who we are as
human beings 99% of us that is where we
are now and it is why we are going to
win this we have everything we need some
still doubt that we have the will to act
but I say the will to act is itself a
renewable resource thank you very much
thank you
thank you
thank you very much
Oh
thank you now
you hit it yeah thank you so thank you
you've you've got this incredible
combination of skills you've got this
scientist mind that can understand the
full range of issues and the ability to
turn it into the most vivid language
neither no one else can do that that's
why you led this thing and it was
amazing to see it 10 years ago is
amazing to see it now well you're nice
to say that Chris but honestly I have a
lot of really good friends in the
scientific community who are incredibly
patient and who will sit there and
explain this stuff to me over and over
and over again until I can get it into
simple enough language that I can
understand it and that's the key to
trying to communicate so you'll talk
first part
terrifying second part incredibly
hopeful how do we know that all those
graphs or that progress is enough to
solve what you showed in the first part
well I think that the crossing of that
you know I've only been in the business
world for 15 years but one of the things
I've learned is that apparently it
matters if a new product or service is
more expensive than the incumbent or
cheaper than it turns out it makes a
difference if it's cheaper than and and
when it it crosses that line then a lot
of things really change we are regularly
surprised by these developments the late
Rudy Doran Bush the great economist said
you know things take longer to happen
than you think they will and then they
happen much faster than you thought they
could I really think that's where we are
some people are using the phrase the
solar singularity now meaning when it
gets below the grid parity unsubsidized
in most places then it's the default
choice now in in in the one of the
presentations yesterday the jitney thing
there is an effort to try to use
regulations to slow this down and I just
don't think it's going to work there's a
woman in Atlanta Debbie Dooley who's the
chairman of the Atlanta tea party they
enlisted her in this effort to put
attacks
on solar panels and regulations and she
had just put solar panels on her roof
and she didn't understand the request
and so she went and and formed an
alliance with the Sierra Club and they
formed a new organization called
the green tea party and and they
defeated the proposal so finally the
answer to your question is at this this
sounds a little corny and maybe it's a
cliche but ten years ago and Christiana
referred to this there are people in
this audience who played an incredibly
significant role in generating those
exponential curves and it didn't work
out economically for some of them but it
kick-started this global revolution and
what people in this audience do now with
the knowledge that we we are going to
win this but it matters a lot how fast
we win it I'll go that was incredibly
powerful if this turns out to be the
year that the partisan thing changes
this is no longer as you said it's no
longer a partisan issue but you bring
along people from the other side
together backed by science backed by
these kinds of eternities backed by
reason that you win the day boy that's
really exciting thank you so much for
making you very much thank you so thank
you
thank you